Media now television is fascinated with
Washington DC and politics it feels like
two-thirds of the shows on television
these days are about Washington when you
look at them is there one that you think
is the most accurate like it is house of
cards accurate or veep or Game of
Thrones is pretty much about Washington
I'm a great believer in free speech
right and I defend the right of people
to say I'm not your things about me and
everybody else but if I was going to
make an exception
I would ban house of cards from being
shown it is the most inaccurate
misleading and unfortunately gives
people a bad idea we suffer from people
saying what's the point of voting it
doesn't do any good none of them can be
trusted
a house of cards just reinforces all of
that inaccurate impression the one the
best show ever done about politics was
West Wing because you choked people what
one good friend of mine comes from you
sell heaping be said about house of
cards first of all we're not that evil
secondly we're not that cover everything
is always working out yeah yeah if the
guy house of cards was in the escape
room he'd have been out of there in a
minute and a half
yeah which isn't real life yeah and in
West Wing you saw real people trying to
do the right thing and stuff in that toe
and getting it wrong and then getting it
right so West Wing which by far the best
house of cards negative ID I don't watch
a lot of the others to be honest right
well Frank Underwood on house of cards
is like sneaking out of the White House
to murder people and then sneak back in
and no one's on to him he's pretty good
but it and unfortunately people get
their views of what reality is from
watching it right and if you if you
watch things like that then I can
understand why people say well what's
the point of voting it's all it's all
terrible right you got the cynicism in
your book is fantastic in your book you
talk a lot about how you are naturally
drawn to the underdog your entire life
starting when you were a kid what was
that all about what do you think I you
know like to psychologize yourself and I
like to think I did it because it was
right on the other hand I can't discount
the possibility that my attraction to
helping minorities
is facing part of my being a gay
left-handed Jew right there are not many
majorities of which I am a member so
it's gotta be kind of self the same well
you've you take yourself to task for it
in the you call yourself use the word
coward you say that you took you a while
to come out and say that you were gay
and you call yourself a coward for that
but at the same time you never did
anything to impede progress I I had a
chance to get out to to the state
legislature I very much wanted to try
and make things better in the world I
knew this is 1972 that if I was honest
about being gay I would never get
elected so I made two decisions one I
would be a coward that is I would not I
never hide about it but I wouldn't tell
the truth about myself which was
somewhat cowdery on the other hand I
made this decision I would never be a
hypocrite and I have absolute contempt
for gay men you generally say gay men
and lesbians but for some reason
lesbians don't pull this crap only the
gay guys do it is to get elected to
office as a gay man and live as a gay
person but then to cover yourself
support anti gay activity that's
hypocrisy the notion that you would give
one way and then punish other people
through your position of authority
because they acted that way that was
awful so I've always felt yeah either
the right to privacy but that does not
become a shield for hypocrisy
you